when you type your name into google a
lot of articles come
come up about your hairstyle wait
i'm really glad that's the autofit and
not like cold sprouts
feet or something disgusting yeah
hair that's a relief right that seems
pretty low-key
in 2021 i'm glad it's about here yes
exactly
um you really are an interesting person
with interesting opinions so i did want
to get your take on some current pop
culture trends are you in
yeah let's go okay because we're calling
it the coal pole
[Applause]
[Music]
okay while riverdale has been on hiatus
it seems like everyone's been bitching
at netflix's bridgerton what do you
think paul
i think those are some of the most
beautiful actors i've ever seen in my
life
um i can't say i've watched too much of
it but i've heard a lot about the sex
scenes
which seem to be incredible according to
tick tock
uh but i haven't seen it um though i do
love the fashion
and the hair styling there
it's so good and they just came on the
show
and it was dynamic to speak to them
because they
are waking everybody up
okay next i just read an article on
buzzfeed about pandemic tattoos
should we all be passing the time right
now by getting some ink
what do you think well you know my
generation has been doing stick and
pokes inside their house for like the
last
10 years i i have a feeling everyone's
gonna
walk away with a tattoo i just don't
know if the origin story sounds too good
you know again i got this because i was
super
bored and i wanted to stick and poke my
friends during one of the biggest
pandemics in global history you know i
just don't think it really
it's not a good origin story my dad is
covered in tattoos and he
he had a little saying which i take with
me which is you should think about a
tattoo for nine months because that's
the time it takes to have a child and
that's a lifelong decision
oh that's really profound and perfect
i had a stick and poke uh tattoo once by
billy joe the lead singer of green day
that's way cooler of an origin story it
disappeared though
which is fine right well next time he's
really got to use the hammer and chisel
it seemed like a fun idea at the time
but then when it disappeared i was like
and there it goes
um sex in the city is coming back with
an
hbo max reboot but without the samantha
character
cole is it still really sex in the city
which one is samantha i've never
okay i watch i watch sex in the city a
little bit
she's the one standing up in the back
patrol
she was in mannequin she's like
everything um
i was watching sex in the city while i
was doing a tv show
and it she affected my performance a lot
like everything i started doing um
sounded
like samantha her um i'll i'll do the
samantha for you
okay hold on um so here would be a
samantha well sex in the city is getting
a reboot
like yes
so she's not gonna be on it she's not
gonna be on it
and um again everything she said was
about sex
it sounds like the cast of riverdale
when the cameras are not rolling
oh that's fun makes going to work better
yeah reboots uh reboots are a tricky
thing
you know uh you have the the
the original shows when they become
successful sit within this
golden little plate of nostalgia and
when you modernize it and go back to it
it has the potential to
really disenfranchise the original fan
base so it's a very very touchy thing
um i'm asked all the time if dawn and i
are going to do a sweet life reboot and
i go
no absolutely not well then i'll skip
the next question
all right chess is everywhere right now
um thanks to the queen's gambit
chess fan um i can't say i'm a chess
fan i know how to play but let's be
honest it's really cool to watch
her play it when it's on a netflix
show you know she makes it look
fantastic
but when was the last time you actually
sat and played chess
it's not the most exciting game and i
grew up
spoiled with video games
and that's such an interactive medium
and
i can't go from playing a man surviving
the apocalypse
to chats
it's true actually i think uh it's the
video game industry just surpassed the
music industry at 180 billion dollars
of 2020's annual revenue so
everyone is being desensitized call
it's happening it's real i do wonder
like
you're an archaeologist i mean man since
the beginning of time
didn't live in a virtual reality world
do you think we're gonna be okay
i it is intriguing how the entertainment
mediums have evolved over time
we had audio then we had visual
now we have virtual reality which truly
takes over most of our senses
and we're fully interactive i have a
feeling and i'm i don't know i'm one of
these guys that
watched wally and saw like the big
people in the chairs floating around the
humans in space and got really excited
i am excited for when i'm 80 years old
and i can just
sit in my virtual reality chair and be
riding some unicorn across
like some apocalyptic plane and i will
my legs might you know my body might be
old
but i get to fully immerse myself into a
virtual world of mine 80. that's gonna
i'm excited for video games when i'm an
old man so i can just
plug in well you just i want to enter
the matrix and i don't want to realize
i'm in the matrix you know
i don't know you just brought a poetry
and romance to the apocalypse though so
thank you for that you're welcome oh i
heard
um that you had a little crush on
jennifer aniston
when you were a kid doing friends is
that true yeah
yeah i did it actually made it quite
difficult to work in front of her i must
admit
i was a child i would stammer a lot and
i'd forget my lines
which uh i i feel like i've maintained
my composure a bit more effectively now
but it was quite difficult when i was a
kid and i was teased a little bit by the
crew
because they saw it and i would just
forget and be looking at her
and the whole world had a crush on
jennifer so
well the whole world has a crush on you
too cole so
at this point i'll take whatever i can
get well
i will take this opportunity to finally
meet you uh someone i have watched
and cheered on along the way and really
like watching you become who you are has
just been fascinating because there's so
much to you
well thank you so much and thank you for
having me on the show drew i appreciate
it
i couldn't be more grateful thank you so
much
the pleasure and the honor
to meet you in person my dear i look so
forward to it
perhaps much sooner than later and the
riverdale
season 5 premieres tomorrow night on the
[Music]
cw